good morning believe nation today's
message is failure is okay over to you
Jessica Simpson the most empowering
lesson that I have learned is failure is
okay sometimes and in that we grow and
we learn from that and there's success
around the corner and you know we have
done so many different things within
growing this brand and it just continues
it continues to keep on keeping on and
we're just very very blessed and when I
say where I'm it's not just me that is
my brand there are so many people that
deserve the credit for the Jessica
Simpson Collection so one of the things
that always surprises me with
entrepreneurs is we expect to get it
right the first time we expect to be an
instant success with our first business
idea we're in reality you fail at
everything the first time you try it
right the first time you pick up a
language the first time you try to rip
stick the first time you try to ride a
bicycle or snowboard you fail you fall
that's normal it's natural and people
who start their first business and it
doesn't work out they feel like a total
failure and they feel like
entrepreneurship visit for them and they
go back and get a job and give up on
their dream we're in reality it's normal
to fail that's going to happen to almost
everybody and so if you failed don't let
that hold you back from continue to try
you know if I really wanted to hop that
curb on my ripstik I could practice I
could look up youtube videos and how to
do it and learn from it and go back and
with persistence and dedication I would
be able to get it and it's the same
thing with your business it's the same
thing whatever challenges ahead of you
right now you're going to fail and suck
at the start and with practice and
mentoring and learning and dedication
you'll get better so my question the day
for you today is I want to know what
you're failing at right now what are you
just sucking at so badly right now where
are you failing leave in the comments
below I'm going to read it I'm going to
check it out I'm gonna join
discussion thank you so much for
watching you need to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presser